this is a super interesting story that
we've actually been covering for several
months there's this guy named neil
cavuto he's a host on fox news fox
business and neil cavuto
had cancer
has multiple sclerosis
and recently got covered for the second
time the second time and he ended up in
the icu
and the interesting thing about neil
cavuto is when he came back from his
first bout with covid which was much
less serious
he kind of admonished people in his
audience for sending him messages about
how they want him to die and he kind of
confronted his own audience and said go
and get the vaccine
he now has again
come back
and called out his own audience after he
ended up
very seriously ill with kovid and he
says i was told had i not been
vaccinated i wouldn't even be here i'm
just telling it to you the way it is and
the fact that this guy
constantly has to call out his own
audience for their false beliefs is
really something but good for him for
doing it check out what he had to say
yesterday so i wasn't really hiding
anything i just felt that i wasn't the
story the stories on this show were and
are the story it's about you it's not
about me just like this show my opinions
don't matter you matter the news matters
but this did drag on a long time for me
so you really do deserve an explanation
from me and here goes
i did get covet again but a far far more
serious strand what doctors call cover
pneumonia it landed me in intensive care
for quite a while and it really was
touch and go some of you who wanted to
put me out of my misery darn near got
what you wish for so sorry to disappoint
you but no the vaccine didn't cause that
that grassy knoll theory has come up a
lot
my very compromised immune system did
because i've had cancer and right now i
have multiple sclerosis i'm among the
vulnerable three percenters or so the
population that cannot sustain the full
benefits of a vaccine in other words it
simply doesn't last but let me be clear
doctors say had i not been vaccinated at
all i wouldn't be here it provided some
defense but that is still better than no
defense maybe not great comfort for some
of you and frankly not great comfort for
me either
this was scary how scary i'm talking
ponderosa suddenly out of the prime rib
in the middle of the buffet line scary
that's how scared
no matter i'm not here to debate
vaccinations for you just offer an
explanation for me
i owe you that i didn't want to become
the story but for many of you i did
so now you know the story
time to get back to far more important
matters the the degree i mean listen
if your audience
is so unhinged and weaponized
that this regularly you have to explain
to them
simple realities about vaccination and
covid maybe this isn't the right
audience for you and of course i'm not
like a big defender of neil cavuto i for
the for the most part i find his
political views just kind of uh
um
mildly disgusting in the sense of like
yeah he's he's just kind of like a
center-right primarily economic
right-winger and i don't agree with him
on much but his audience
seems absolutely horrible and of course
we know that they are just think back a
few months ago when he had kova the
first time maybe this was more like uh i
guess this was about six months ago
he shared some of the emails he got from
people wishing him dead
uh we've got a tj who also emails it's
clear you've lost some weight with all
this stuff good for you but i'm not
happy with less of you i want none of
you i want you gone dead kaput fenit get
it now take your two-bit advice
deep six it and you
that's uh rather harsh neil so
uh but i figured i'd relate that to you
for the sopranos uh prequel yes it does
sound kind of like that okay now we got
vince
vince tweets hey guys i bought a new car
after being told it was the best then i
blew up after i left the car lot so now
i'm begging everyone to please buy the
same car sorry i would just pretend to
be neil cavuto which i think is uh being
a little uh sarcastic there in that last
tweet
you think a little bit a little bit a
little bit okay i know you love that
here's another tweet politifact
politifact bias neil cavuto has been
fully vaccinated for months and has been
a vocal advocate about the safety and
efficacy of covet vaccines publicly and
repeated repeatedly on air this is not a
new position for him which is true neil
this is not a new position and that's
kind of what we were stressing you know
seriously look this is something from
the very beginning i've been saying that
i think the better part of valor is if
you haven't been vaccinated it might be
a good idea for you to get vaccine i
understand those for religious personal
reasons don't want it but i understand
also the numbers that the more who do
get vaccinated the the bigger the drop
in in cases absolutely yeah didn't fall
on all receptive ears no clearly not i
got another one for you ignis aspiring
to aspire tweets cavuto is the tigger of
talking heads okay anyway i think you
guys get it and this has been something
he's been dealing with for a while and
this was his and again we covered this
at the time he's been doing this for a
month and his audience just doesn't seem
to get it here he is begging people
think about someone other than yourself
when it comes to the vaccine we've lost
5 million globally to this we've lost
nearly 800 000 in the us take the
political speaking points and toss them
for now i'm begging you toss them and
think of what's good not only for
yourself but for those around you if you
don't want to do it for yourself if you
think it's a pain in the ass i get that
right but think of others around you i
dare say people who experience this or
seen loved ones who've been affected by
this or have never died from this are
not judging the wisdom of mandates
they're wishing they got vaccinated and
they didn't i'm
listen i sometimes have disagreements
with like a sliver of my audience there
are people who disagree with me on my
take on russia ukraine there are people
who disagree with me on my take on
hate crime enhancements or cuba or
venezuela or crypto or you know whatever
whatever
um but if the majority of my audience
seemed to be at odds with the fact that
i think the vaccines
protect you from dying from covid which
is what the science shows
i accept rather i accept not i think or
believe
um i would be reconsidering what the
hell i'm doing now my situation's
different because i am my own platform
in the sense that cavuto has taken his
views and he works at fox and he has the
fox audience okay
if he went somewhere else he would have
a different audience presumably i don't
know how many people are super loyal to
kavuto but he seems sort of uninspiring
in that way it's not the same for
someone like me
in the sense that we're on platforms
where you can just watch somebody else
and so i don't think i would end up in a
situation where where such a significant
portion of my audience disagrees with me
about something so fundamental but these
are people where nothing will change
their mind at this point in time and we
know the numbers we know the data we
know everything although i don't agree
with neil cavuto politically i'm glad he
didn't die i'm glad he was vaccinated
and i see no reason to question what the
doctors told him
which is at the level of severity that
you got sick this time in the icu
if you were not fully vaccinated it's
likely that you would have died that
seems reasonable to me
and uh whether this will change
anybody's mind in cavuto's audience i
have absolutely no idea